these [__] dogs 9:00 in the morning
[__] are barking I have to get
Mike Vic in this neighborhood just
cleaning up these [__] oh [__]
I'm happy you [__] join me on
this morning it's a beautiful day to be
alive you dare enter this
[Music]
that's how we're doing it on the Lord's
Day on a Sunday morning
I've been up nice and early tip-top
Magoo went over the church let these
[__] know it the Catholic
Church who the [__] running things I
got my little cookie I put a fit in the
basket I got the [__] out of there
before they started spewing this [__] on
to my ears uncle Joey here Sunday
November 19th
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive the birds are chirping the sun's
out but most importantly you're alive
and [__] kicking a lot of
people walking around I'm [__] up and
here you are walking around swinging
dick back to your same nonsense talking
[__] well let me taste some
[__]
it's dirty something days away from
Christmas and you're still [__]
around it's gotta be 30 something days
to New Year's and you're still [__]
around no New Year's resolution what
you're gonna do next year how you gonna
make that [__] happen well let's get
that process started today because
[__] time flew this year as you saw
here you are a Subway sandwich you're an
assistant manager and guess what you're
still an assistant manager but we ain't
got time for this or that it's time to
part spark the Holy Smoke of life I got
three tremendous briefest bag I got blue
cookies from perennial I got the talent
on the great boat G which is a killer
from Manila and this is the classic load
G it's my goal to weed you know I'm
saying besides that it's gonna be a
great week for you kind of but it would
be a great way for your family I got on
Twitter last night ten o'clock before I
went to bed somebody it's on they're
talking about [__] this and that the
side boy listen who gives a [__] it's
Thanksgiving week
who gives a [__] it's Thanksgiving week
ok it's a week to be with your family
it's a week to reflect it's a week to
give thanks Joey
what's with the [__] here beatin
let's the pocket I know hey but it's
true
it's a [__] week to figure out what
the [__] is gonna do what a [__] were
you last year at this time what a
[__] you list you at this time
you follow me but it'll give us a [__]
for right now let's smoke some reefer
partake as the church family that we all
remember I'm with you you're with me and
they want to be with us we've always
been together since day one [__] all
that nonsense tremendous I enjoy this
little [__] Tecate that we get to do
on the Lord's Day because this is how
you plan your week while all these
idiots a [__] sleep and who's gonna
win the game
what plotline next [__] move a man
without a plan is not a man so you're
plotting your next move all week Monday
Tuesday I had it done for a [__]
schedule who are gonna humiliate who are
gonna hunt honey Malia who won't let me
get under their skin to give us what the
[__] we need understand me because like
Mick Jagger says he can't get what [__]
one but you get what you need
you found him saying to you
[__] take notes it's the Lord's
Day scratch your [__] powder your balls
it's gonna be a [__] phenomenal week
okay they're gonna have to shoot you
with a [__] grenade to [__] stop
I might well it's all about you feeling
down you feeling depressed we'll take a
shower I take a walk around the block
five times you're doing inventory it was
the last time you had a long
[__] top of yourself that's
what I did this week and I've been
slipping awful and that's what we do his
family
you [__] catch me and I catch you do
I embarrass you
no we pull your side a dog get it
together put the batteries back in all
you want I'm a beat-up guitar hole here
doggy anyway Joey let's do another
[__] ball it's an early day you
doesn't know what it go this is what
Jesus wanted you to do with smoke balls
in the morning and talk with your family
and plot out what the [__] you next move
is as a family you follow me oh [__]
let's blue cookies got low sativa tea
next day you know you're running around
like [__] out fright and feeling up
chicks titties and [__] like that these
[__] don't wanna get caught bro
what if I've always told you I hate
sneaky [__] sneaky
[__] are the worst me I do
something I do it in your [__] face
and then I tell you about that's why a
lot of people don't like because I don't
give a [__] I've never liked sneaky
[__]
is there an edition can they take that
cute I've never thought I was cute
everything I've done because it's my
pure [__] stupidity
not because of [__] cuteness you
following everything but this whole
society wants to be cute then when they
get bitch-slapped they cry like Kathy
Griffin you tried to be cute and funny a
little [__] [__] friends where'd it
get you don't worry about your friends
your friends ain't gonna bail you out
when you [__] not doing dick it's all
about you make the [__] decision get
in the [__] movie listen I plan
everything out
I hope you guys I used to be a runaway
hit the rock or one of those [__]
Indians no no I plan every [__] move
strategically because we ain't got many
[__] moves left
so the moves you got you gotta make
[__] hit you mean that time they hit
some guy with a [__] slap you got to
hit him with a [__] railroad tie over
there that's better you proof that's it
less strokes
more [__] damage
for these cups dirty grand a year this
little chasing people 8 in the morning
get the [__] out of here anyway you know
I love you [__] this week I
don't have much for you I got to podcast
tonight and Tuesday I'm gonna set you
off Thanksgiving with a nice little
collection all right what do we got we
got a Wednesday in Irvine it's old that
I got Tuesday at the store maybe I'm not
sure no we got a podcaster I can't even
bother my trying to swing tonight Monday
night just to get ready for Wednesday
then December third fourth and fifth
wheeler Walker jr. we started [__]
novo Theatre here right here in Los
Angeles Monday night the fifth I think
would [__] San Diego the fourth and
then the fifth when Santa had a man we
were walking to tear that [__]
up me on the stage him on the guitar and
the drums were gonna bring a tuba in
there are you [__] kidding me or what
Sacramento the 7th 8th and 9th enjoy
with ties for the year I get my little
ear surgery so I can hear better my
[__] equilibrium a long way to date
so many edibles to balance out this side
of the [__] here Joey
what do I want I need a detailed 10 I
know Joey sparked that [__] ball I
know mine already
I wish it was this good news and if we
get it we get it if not we move on we go
around the [__] side door mudichu
guys that know ain't the end of the
[__] world
and lived off the word [__] no that's
what gets up that's what makes you get
up in the morning the more knows I hear
the closer I am to my [__] that
knocking on that [__] door you know
Zed I don't get discouraged by you know
smoke a bowl get the notebook and plan
your next [__] moves on Chico now
without further ado that's it and that's
that don't forget if you're a fat [__]
you're joining jujitsu this week Fugees
go to fuji sports.com put in church i'm
gonna give you a 10% off i'm the
superego the right door the psycho is a
good s/he Iko is a good guy but my
favorite [__] uh key from fuji his
ass are burrito
i got in white black and blue tremendous
it's light these [__] people when I'm
in their God their dog and their dog and
they're talking like that climbing the
wall I'm Batman but then get in the
window and the gate ripping so there you
have a little Fuji sports dumb uncle
Joey's gonna help you out and I said man
you know I'm Sam with that they gather
in the morning people wish they could do
this get together with their uncle talk
a little [__] plan out the week we have
to church page not [__] laying
knowledge on there Amen you know I'd
rather you drop what's going on with
your life then stupid [__] so if you
have a problem put it on now get to you
you know the wife yeah headache you
don't know what to do nobody knows what
to do that's why you gotta sit back guys
that's why you got your uncle [__]
Joey
you follow me decide that that's it and
that's that let's do another poll what
do you think what which offer where we
[__] camp fire girls we show up to
smoke reefer ok so we did the great no
we did the [__] the blue cookies we
did the [__] classic well let's do
the grape OG from here I don't want to
break this cos this ended
but no cops no cops bacon two eggs piece
of weak toast maybe what's it
I'm trying people I'm still a fat [__]
but I'm in the game every day you follow
me some days you have good days some
days you have bad days as long as you
don't need to cert you're okay and
that's it that's it nights that like I
said to you I got a wife I got a kid I
got a podcast I got my little brother
Lee I got my brothers I got a comedy
this periscope on the Lord's Day this
little thing we do
Macey my [__] to you but this is big
this is bigger than what the [__] you
think guys we're together we'll start
not they're together I'm anything my
mind put [__] in mundo sorry they
call a song here that might say wound oh
oh yeah doula painting hello my Bhutan
typical oh yes in my opinion no way
that's a lie ain't that a bingo ayah
what I said about this hard body soul
will the church [__]
we got time to [__] around they drop the
bomb there's gonna be roaches a couple
rats and six members from the church
walking around with missing eyeballs you
follow me but wish they're gonna be here
listen go out there this week [__] him
up [__] him in the ass Monday Tuesday
Wednesday sit down
yeah hang out you [__] eat with your
family you watch the football you give
them all a hug tell him you love him
tell him how [__] with luck we are I
never grew up with a [__] family I
always say Thanksgiving and other
people's families houses but I've
learned a lot from them I learned about
love and what family was all about and I
wish I always yearned for that if I had
a way I get the [__] church family to
get together we put together 92 [__]
turkeys and put a [__] joint each one
of their mouths and [__] make them
smoke and then we eat the [__]
well after that point yet so uh
Thursday's a big day for you and your
family but you know what as usual
well that door [__] periscope
Thursday just to prove to these [__]
[__] a thing I'd dick on us with
a church family [__] second for
the Gambino's and we're [__] taking
over and we ain't shooting nobody who's
better than us remember it's the Lord's
Day thank God for giving you another day
I don't give a [__] where you got his
Jewish black Muhammad's arm ball it
don't matter give him another day thank
him for him another day to sling dick
like a [__] and compose your
will on these [__] Gentiles walking
around drinking Starbucks oh my god I
love my new glasses go [__] yourself I'm
slamming dick I'm showing up with a
[__] anyway oh yeah they didn't come
home until I paint ahoy I'll see you
tonight 8:00 o'clock I'll see you
Tuesday at some point add a button ah
see you Wednesday night perfect
let's say [__] have a
phenomenal day hug your families
I'll get cats but always in the back of
your mind get ready and let him
[__] know that if he slips at
all he's gonna have to suck your big
robot dick cuz the church said you [__]
have a good day